argentina está en llamas desde hace
semanas y según datos oficiales la mano
del ser humano es responsable del 95 por
ciento de los incendios registrados ya
sea por intereses en inversiones
inmobiliarias o mineras o por las quemas
por parte de ganaderos para renovar el
pasto y ampliar sus terrenos de las 14
provincias afectadas 12 siguen teniendo
focos activos siendo córdoba y jujuy las
más críticas en el delta del paraná
ecosistema de humedales clave por su
biodiversidad
los incendios llevan activos desde junio
y el ministerio de medioambiente
argentino presentó una querella para
averiguar quiénes son responsables de
este ecocidio sin embargo organizaciones
ambientales denuncian que el gobierno no
está haciendo lo suficiente para
combatir las llamas la medida para
controlar el fuego en las provincias
afectadas son insuficientes exigimos que
se amplíen significativamente los fondos
y la infraestructura destinados a la
prevención y lucha contra los incendios
la vecina paraguay está en las mismas la
región occidental o chaco es la más
afectada con él
cinco de los focos la fuerte sequía que
azota al país sumada a las altas
temperaturas registradas a pesar de que
acaba de comenzar la primavera están
avivando las llamas que muchas veces
inician con la quema de pastizales
que quiera controlar imposible
incontrolable el primero de octubre el
gobierno paraguayo declaró la emergencia
nacional lo que desbloquea fondos y
permite pedir ayuda internacional para
combatir los incendios